you said um you were using to talk talk
to me a bit about i mean what a life
you've had you know um
it's
it's kind of similar to a lot of other
people that go through addiction uh you
know it started off great it started off
as fun uh
partying and clubbing and you know my
job kind of
meant i had longer hours than most
people are being out and you know it was
a natural progression it was organically
you know
it went from alcohol to drugs
and i would take little bits of whatever
to keep myself awake at work and then it
just progressed and progressed and then
i regressed
and you know uh 28 years of using the
last 10 were weren't alive it was
survival
uh you know um and it was it was hell i
at the end i weighed seven stone i
lost all my teeth i pulled all
the majority of my teeth out with
bits of wood and pliers and anything i
could find to get just get it out my
mouth because i had a thing called meth
mouth with my mouth i thought i had
animals that were in my mouth and you
know i was completely insane
yeah what happened
uh
what do you mean in the end how i
changed it how did you change you know
all it took was the love of one person
to save me you know all i thought about
was dying on a daily basis for a good
year and a half all i ever thought about
was my funeral and then one night i was
in a in a in a club and in the back room
rocking backwards and forwards as i did
digging up the last two thinking that i
uh i knew i had to go and dj
and i and i you know i i
couldn't look at anyone i couldn't look
at anyone i hadn't looked at people in
the eyes for a long time and and in
walked my partner at the time and police
and i looked at him and i thought i
can't deal with this tonight
you know because i'd already been out
for three days and he literally just
came and put his hand on my shoulder and
i looked up at him and i always start to
cry at this point because he all he said
to me was what happened to you
and i just broke it i just cried because
it was that god-given moment that
changed my life because there was no
judgment in it and it was suddenly like
a little the pilot light came back on it
was that that's all it took it was a you
know it was a god-given moment he should
not have been there you know and there
was no judgment in it and it and off i
went to
uh for six months of trying to get clean
i went to
drug dropping centers i i went to a
12-step program
and then eventually i went to rehab for
six months
uh and then came forward to london
and came forward to my career and
you know i it was just about
the minute that we start to believe
everything changes
you